hello everyone I'm Elaine and today I'm
going to show you how to model acoustic
systems in the war foreign language and
the modeling process is based on solving
a set of partial differential equations
so let me introduce a bit what PDE motto
is so a PDE model is a set of
mathematical equations that can describe
the physical phenomena in the real life
so for example in acoustics we use wave
equation to describe the some way in
time and in flu dynamics we use
navier-stokes equation to describe the
flow field and with all these
mathematical equations we can build PDE
model for the computer simulation but
one difficulty in solving a PDE model is
that most of the time we can we are not
able to get an analytical solution
because the complexity of our system but
in the whorfin language we have many
powerful building functions such as
undie soft they can do such tests for
you they can use the finite element
method or finite difference method
depends on what you like
so as the star point we are now
developing the tutorial in acoustics to
show users how to build acoustics model
in the Wolfram language in Mathematica
so in the following sections I will show
you how to build acoustics models in the
Wolfram language and two for both title
time domain and frequency domain
analysis and I will show you how to set
the acoustics PDE how to model some
sources and various type of some medium
and I will also show you how to use the
building function in the Wolfram
language to map the acoustics boundary
condition in our language
but Before we jump into each step let me
give you a sense of the whole modeling
process so for example we are modeling a
mountain a fleur and automobile muffler
and we are interesting in the
performance at different frequencies so
we perform the analysis in the frequency
domain and the modeling process can be
divided into five steps first we have to
define our domain and then we specify
the boundary conditions and we set our
PDE model and then we solve our PD model
numerically using the building function
and dissolve and finally we can do
post-processing and the visualization to
to check our results so consider another
case if we are we want to study the
sound propagation in time the whole
modeling process is very similar the
only difference is that besides defining
the boundary conditions we also have to
give the initial condition of our
simulation domain so in this example I'm
showing the tongue diffraction pattern
in the 2d domain and let me show you the
result in Mathematica here it is so we
can study the diffraction pattern yeah
so okay now let me show you how to
define the acoustics PDE in the open
language so for the time domain analysis
we use wave equation as our PDE and the
primary variable is the strong pressure
P here
and ro stands for the density of our
song medium and C stand for the speed of
sound and F and Q stands for the
optional song source we can add to our
acoustic system which I will explain a
little more in the following section and
in the frequency domain we use Helmholtz
equation as our governing PDE so unlike
the wave equation Helmholtz equation is
a stationary equation and there's a
angular frequency term in our home whose
equation and you may notice in both
equation we have a common part and I
highlighted in blue so in the tutorial
we have already defined a help function
called
acoustics model so as a user you can
define both PDE with only one line code
so next I will show you how to model
some source in the Wolfram language and
the two common some source in acoustics
are multiple source and type of source
so a monopole source is a point source
that radiates the song isotopically so
let me first show you what it looks like
it looks like this so to build to define
the monopole source in the foreign
language we have to add an extra term
when we define our PDE so um the
monopole source R denotes by the symbol
Q here and it's equal to the amplitude
of the source and the direct Delta
located at the source location but as a
user you only have to define the
amplitude of your monopole source as
well as the location and the frequency
of your
source we already define a help function
for you to do the calculation here and
and then in this example I demonstrate
the result in the time domain so the
setup of the PDE the code here
corresponds to the upper equation upper
formula so the frequency domain one is
just for reference and yeah so let's see
the result again and the plot I write is
the strong amplitude distribution so the
song has the maximum values near the
source location and the case as it
propagates far away from their source so
how about the type of source unlike a
multiple source the dipole source didn't
radiates the song isotropically so let
me show you so if you want to define a
dipole source in for your acoustic
systems you have to define the amplitude
of this dipole and the source location
the frequency but you also have to
define the orientation of your type of
source so here in this example I define
the orientation as 45 degrees so the the
modeling process is very similar to
model in multiple source you also have
to modify your PDE and the dipole is
denotes by the symbol F here so we also
have a help function to do the
calculation here for you and here is
what how we said set up our PDE with the
typo source so because I set the
orientation as 45 degrees you can see
the amplitude of the type
source has the maximum value along the
line in 45 degrees in this plot so next
let me show you how to model the Sun in
various types of medium including the
homo in the Wolfram language we can
model the Sun in homogeneous median and
in homogeneous media and we can also
model a Luci media where the Sun keeps
decaying within the domain so I think
example I I will show you how to build a
model the song in the Luci media so to
view this model we have to add an extra
dissipation term when we define our PDE
and I highlighted in blue and this
dissipation term is defined by the floor
resistivity and the porosity of the Lucy
media and the modeling process is the
first step is we define our domain and
we set up our modified version of the
PDE which equals to the original PDE
plus the extra term extra dissipation
term and here I set up a boundary
condition to produce the incoming some
wave from the left and we solve it
in undies off and let's see the result
so as you see the song keeps decaying as
it propagates through the domain okay
so next let me show you how to use the
building function in Mathematica to map
the acoustic boundary conditions so the
acoustic boundary condition can be
catalog categorized into three types the
robbing Neumann type and the original
type for robbing type and Neumann type
we can use the building function
called Newman value to map these
boundary conditions and for directional
type of boundary condition we use the
function called their virtual condition
so let me show you example how to map
the impedance boundary condition in the
wolfin language so the but let me
introduce what impedance boundary is and
what is the purpose purpose of using it
so imagine we are modeling a song
propagate from one material to another
because the density and the speed of
song are different when the Sun
propagates across the median some part
of the way will be reflected and some
part of the way will transmit to the
interface so looks like this yeah but so
we can build this model in foreign
language and we define the domain
consists of both medium 1 and medium 2
but what if we only interest in the
region of medium 1 it will be very
inefficient with if we view the whole
domain consists of both medium 1 and
medium 2 but we are not interest in the
medium the region of medium 2 so in this
case we can use the impedance boundary
condition to model the media interface
here so that we can only our
computational domain only consists of
the medium one and here is the formula
of the impedance boundary condition but
I didn't put the derivation here because
you will take like 10 more pages but if
you are interested in the derivation we
have put all the derivation and
explanation in our tutorial and you can
always refers to that so we define the
impedance boundary condition using the
building function Newman value
here because impedance boundary
condition is rubbing type boundary
condition and let's see the result
so the our result is exactly the same as
the left-hand side of our previous
animation but now it is much more
efficient because our computational
domains like only in medium one so lest
I would like to introduce a modeling
method called
perfectly matched layer and how we
implement this in the Wolfram language
so perfect PML is a method to model the
simulation domain within finite
extension so imagine we are modeling a
sound wave coming from left and to to
the right and all the way down to
infinity but clearly we cannot have a
simulation domain within finite
extension so if we simply truncate our
domain and do nothing at the boundary
then the result will looks like this the
wave will be reflected to our domain and
interfere with the incoming wave so to
solve this issue we can use the PML PML
is a an extension region attached to our
original simulation domain and we think
the PML region the wave will be
continuous so that at the boundary the
wave didn't reflect back to our original
domain so looks like this so if you
focus on our original simulation domain
it looks like the wave propagate from
left to all the way to infinity so yeah
to implement the PML
in the Wolfram language we have to
modify our PDE so the black part is the
original PDE the part highlight in blue
is
extra term so s here stands for the
variables that can control the
continuation within the PML region and
the it depends on the Sigma which is the
episode absorbing coefficient and this
is chosen by users so the modeling
process is the same as previous the only
two things you have to do is you have to
enlarge your domain to include the PML
region and then you have to use set set
the PDE with the transform version here
so now let's put everything together and
do an application example so this is the
muffler I should show you previously but
now we will go through the process
step-by-step so first we define our 3d
domain and here I use the boolean
operator to - yeah to define the domain
and then I set the boundary condition in
the inlet I use the radiation boundary
condition to produce the incoming wave
and at the outlet I apply an absorbing
boundary condition to avoid the wave
reflection so then I solve our PDE model
using the undies parametric undies so
across the frequency range I'm
interesting so now the frequency range I
want to study is from 15 Hertz to 1,500
Hertz
and now we got the result and we can
visualize our result so the left plot is
the sum distribution within the muffler
you can see the amplitude at the inlet
is its high but at outlet the song has
been dissipated by the muffler and yes
and one property to quantify the
performance of a muffler is called
transmission loss it calculate the how
much sound has been dissipated by the
muffler and here is the formula which
you can find in many acoustics books and
after sound is a after some calculation
I got the plot here and based on this
plot I can know out which frequencies
the muffler do the job the best and
based on this we can also improve the
design of our muffler and if you are
interested in the icon frequency and the
eigen mode of your system you can solve
the PDE model using the building
function code and the eigen system and
you said you gave the function how many
iconic frequencies and eigen modes you
want and the output will be a list of
eigen frequencies and here is the
visualization so this is pretty much how
we model and acoustic systems in the
warfarin language but like acoustics is
just the start point of our project our
ultimate goal is to apply the warfarin
language in many other areas so we can
help users in each specific field and
they can build our beaut their models
and do the analysis in the woven
language
so thank you very much for attention
which bill do you think we should do the
next and you if you have any questions
or comments P you are more than welcome
to send me an email or i-x me next
thank you very much
[Applause]